ça robert charlebois bonsoir voila quand
est venu en france pour la première fois
c'est en 69
c'est une belle rencontre succès oui ça
fait l'olympia avec georgette plana ce
que je veux de l'amour luxe même si la
suite
alyzia québécois une belette américaine
c'est l humour le député en vedette
chinoise
georgette plana et être en vedette
américaine de l'aude à scott qui est
elle-même en vedette japonaise de
liliane c'est sûr qu'ils étaient
reprendre vedette de chipie quad et la
grande le destin avait commencé à
chanter un an avant and your 68
oui je faisais des petites boîtes
le cyclope et à l'époque où ou des lieux
ne s'est pas encore l'appeler pop
c'est vrai qu'il chantait une fois
devoir médiévale à l'époque m'a dit que
je composais du folklore médiéval ans
parce que je savais que 3 2 ou 3
d'accord dont mi mineur et et ré ré
majeur est que la plupart des chansons
de robert devisy quintet composé au
moyen âge la tfz avec ces deux accords
là alors je m'étais je devais jouer sa
baisse et je n'avais pas le choix
cette période de gloire absolument
énorme j'ai appris douala d'accord ouais
t'as appris tôt de sa forme et ses
chansons électrocuté surtout tu t'es un
peu endormi sur ses lauriers comme
maintenant cette fois il ya des gens qui
disent ça et les gens sont toujours là
vas-y toi ça non y'a quelqu'un dans
l'avion tu me tiens vous chantez
beaucoup mieux qu'avant mais vos
chansons sont moins bon équilibre les
gens disent que pour l'argent mais c'est
pour m'endormir souvenirs mes lauriers
c'est que un moment d'aniche et j'ai
décidé que je voulais pas être le plus
riche du cimetière et que je voulais
prendre le temps de vivre d'élever des
enfants de l'effet l'esa et emmitt mes
deux meilleures chansons c'est édictant
les gênant mais cette attitude cool tu
l'as toujours eu parce que quand tu fais
du cinéma c'est pareil tu as fait un
film qui s'appelait un génie un associé
et de cloche
damiano damiani est supervisé par sergio
leone oui tu jouais avec terrell s'il
tue remplacer le beau spencer aimes yoyo
et un jour c'est le lundi de pâques
l'état fait partir antilles par accor
et mon dieu baisse ce qui explique que
ma carrière au cinéma italien a été très
brève c'est que j'avais demandé à mieux
mieux moi si on travaillait le dit
parquet puis mis mon nom travaille pas
et le lundi matin à 8 heures j'étais au
cap d'antibes mon téléphone sonne c'est
sergio leone avec un goal chargé par
règlement qui faisait il y a deux cents
figurants qui était attendue sur le
plateau j'ai dit si je prends la bagnole
sergio j'arriverai pas 25 heures ce soir
1er l'avion et hanzal et évidemment
lambiel expliqué qu au cinéma ça se
faisait pas que s'ils avaient pas
investit déjà un peu d'argent sur moi
j'aurais et éclairé comme on dit et puis
ensuite car il tend faire la promotion
j'avais un billet réservé pour le club
med d'assinie choix
et puis on dit à nos clients une femme
qui s'appelait choulet siegfried qui me
dit faut venir faire la parade la
promotion que sérieuse non non j'ai un
rêve mais j'ai pris mon diable le club
med a dit si vous ne venez pas faire la
promotion vous n'aurez plus jamais en
france et je n'ai plus jamais toner j
avais fait ou est faible j'ai fait faire
beaucoup d'argent à sergio et je suis
resté bon ami avec lui permet
j'ai eu beaucoup de pincettes un démenti
des morts les indiens sait pas se servir
des plats chez des amis italiens les
espagnols montrer à des indiens comme
maintenir un arrêt commencer les flèches
d'angers ouest l'affichette parce que le
jeu réalisé jusque là qu'elle commence à
peu seraient finalement dégénérescence
part si c'était à refaire
c'est enfin geoffrey tout comme ça
paraît je crois que oui parce que bon 17
les sept années où j'ai vraiment vécu à
élever mes enfants et à savourer la vie
ça a été bon sur le plan professionnel
on peut penser que j'ai rien fait trop
dur on emmagasine toujours des musiques
des images la mer et comprenez ça m'a
même envoyé quelques erreurs
non mais ils m'aimaient beaucoup mieux à
me disais c'est pas parce que tu es mon
fils mais je trouve que je n'utilise
plus objectif et non mais elle me voyait
quelques fois possible et l'on après
midi comme ça plane et puis c'est
nerveusement prénom nom rebelles il ya
quelque chose dans sa tête il est en
train de me préparer quelque chose
alors est ce que tu es prêt robert on va
faire une orgie après 10 tours à faire
une analyse dit
mauritanie tant que vous vous fixez qu'a
rapporté le coup de pot nuon chea
maintenant beaucoup de fric
le plus beau souvenir d'émissions de
télévision de ma vie c'est quand je suis
allé en guadeloupe là il ya deux
semaines faire une émission qui
s'appelle les grandes vacances
oui mon pays un séjour d'une semaine en
guadeloupe chez moi pour faire deux
chansons en playback plus une semaine
sur ce merveilleux bateau sélectionna
douanes où j'ai travaillé une demi-heure
présenté une chanson et en plus j'avais
un cachet assez spectaculaire par
rapport au cash et l'excellent perdu le
plus de pognon plus grosse perte
je crois je crois que c'est quand j'ai
gagné à spa en belgique
il m'avait régler gros paquet francs
comme ça et j'étais à l'époque assez fou
assez fly et je mélangeais les pales à
10h06 ciel avec beaucoup d'appétit et je
m'étais ramassés à pigalle je vois dans
un endroit qui ressemblait beaucoup ta
première émission que de noël il ya deux
ans et je crois je m'étais fait assommer
par des pmp mais je me suis retrouvé
fitou fume avait soulagé de tout mon mon
gain de sport qui est autour de 2000
dollars c'est beaucoup d'argent à
l'époque et tu te mets plus de
l'histoire éclat fillon non ouais je me
souviens juste qu'il y avait un couvre
lit fleuri avec des tapisseries fne un
plafond de ripper un tapis de beaucoup
qui a accouché aujourd'hui l'âge des
étoiles la meilleure défense que t'as
jamais pris je crois que c'était avec
patrick magaud
qui jouait il est vrai que le prisonnier
élimine c'est un héros en vue des gens
qui vivaient du jane mais pour le suivre
j à lui conseillé de suivre un jour sans
succès parce qu'il commençait au gin
tonic le matin vers 10 à aiguèze boulot
si je me disais gainsbourg ça doit être
une rumeur et ça et puis il est venu
faire l'émission de télé il ya deux ans
on m'avait donné rendez vous au bar à 10
heures le matin avec le 26 ans délicat
qui s'est tapé avant le déjeuner alors
pas mangé pendant l'émission et s'est
tapé douzaine de viande et labatt bleue
5 6% et en sortant des missions et aller
au bal et là je crois que ça ça fait des
défenses plus de la cao test je peux
inventer le mourre que n'importe quel
lieu loin ou drogues chimiques ou
cocaïne nights et c'était les bactéries
la défense la défense serait plus
flippante
il fonce la plus flippante plus mauvais
stress que j'ai jamais trouvé à
certaines pilules que j'avais acheté à
san francisco adversaire venait de
sortir d'un laboratoire seulement à
l'époque bien avant l'ex d'acier à
l'époque où il y avait les chocs joss et
de lsd je sais pas quoi bien et est
grosse comme une tête d'épinglé tank
européen dont on va la couper en deux le
haut qui nous l'avait dit je vous
conseille de la couper en 4 on ne dirait
aux autres jusqu'à nador pour
connaisseurs pas pour le couper en deux
et pendant pendant trois jours j'étais
même est capable de signaler un numéro
de téléphone ne savait plus montré que
jusqu'à montrer tu dois y est passé de
foyers proches de synthés ponant ça a
été long c'est bien la fin tu peux
manger un steak trentaine de loges qu'il
reste comme les néons aller allumer
derrière
et je recommande passe à mes enfants
mais non mais non bien sûr que non parce
que tu préfères dangereuse mais comme
toutes les drogues chimiques on sait
jamais dans quoi on peut tomber tu
préfères dans le set
ce que je préfère dans le cercle on
parle d'égalité des sexes n'y en a pas
du domaine de l'eau sans cesser avant et
pendant la pleine post wintour ou un
homme triste homme est bidon l'attaqué
de ce que tu détestes par l'émission
j'avais vu était trop malade le ton
émission bains douches l'aider
sadomasochisme avoir une érection en
léchant uni d'éjaculation énorme
alléchant des semelles de bottes
s'allume ça me dégoûte un peu se font
jour
c'est grave ce que tu aimes le plus sans
toi ce que j'aime le mieux sans moi je
crois que c'est mon sens du mot final
qui est à peu près à toutes épreuves
j'aime bien mélanger jusqu'à audrey fou
ce tableau noir toi c'est peut-être mon
côté pour paresseux milla ouais j'ai
l'esprit d'escalier vraiment sympa
l'émission je dis que j'allais dire ça
ça mais je vais déjà être en train de
claquer la porte
alors c'est ça si j'avais vu un fabre
une autre vie ça serait le sens de la
répartie instantané lorsque tu t'en sors
pas mal
mais pas enfin je connais des gens qui
sont sortis après